[Musique]
ces deux livres intrigant en plus de
raconter sa vie et son parcours
d'entrepreneur l'homme le plus riche du
québec ont choisi de parler des liens
qui ont été faits entre lui et la mafia
mais de mauvaise presse n'avait pas fini
de salaire notre réputation
notre collègue est en poule iode
accumule depuis deux ans des documents
sur lino saputo et des membres de sa
famille
voir notre réputation ternie a été la
paire des difficultés aux est inconnu
avec plusieurs membres de sa famille
lino saputo a réussi de façon
spectaculaire en affaires saputo inc
et maintenant la plus grande entreprise
de produits laitiers de fromage au
canada et la deuxième en importance aux
états unis la campagne un québécois
saputo a de l'appétit saputo à chaptelat
compagne americans elle a fondé
l'entreprise est planétaire
avec plus de 17 mille employés on se
rappelle surtout qu'elle a survécu
linars et c'est joe louis de
l'assimilation à l'américaine inch tb
cuit aujourd'hui la famille saputo
possède une fortune estimée à plus de 6
milliards de dollars seulement que pour
son entreprise par saputo inc
mais ce n'est qu'une partie de leur
richesse
ces gratte-ciel emblématique du centre
ville de montréal sont partis leurs
portefeuilles immobiliers
saputo c'est aussi le saut caire mais la
famille a également des intérêts dans le
camionnage et l'industrie forestière du
nom saputo a littéralement sauvé une
forêt de la faille et la philanthropie
est désormais au coeur des activités de
lino saputo
les documents que notre collègue et en
poule i hate à trouver met en lumière ce
qui cloche dans cette autobiographie
lino saputo ne dit pas tout de l'état de
new york à l'arizona
nous avons déterré des secrets qu'il
espérait enfoui à jamais
[Musique]
à 82 ans line ou saputo a décidé que le
moment est venu de raconter son histoire
quand je fais le bilan je constate à
quel point ma jeunesse à façonner mes
priorités et mes choix
la jeunesse de lino saputo commence au
milieu des années 30 dans le village de
monter les prix en sicile
lino saputo sera le quatrième des huit
enfants de mariah et giuseppe saputo
mon père était un commerçant local et
fromager de métier il tirait sa fierté
de la qualité et du goût de ses fromages
mais la vie change à monter les prix
après la seconde guerre mondiale le sud
de l'italie est en ruine la sicile et
notre village demande et les prix se
sont mis à ressembler au far west la
violence il était mon est courante
la mafia locale s'est mise à jouer un
plus grand rôle dans la vie des gens
[Musique]
les saputo fui cette atmosphère et comme
des centaines de milliers d'autres
italiens à l'époque il tente de se
construire une vie meilleure au canada
le 8 décembre 1952 nous avons débarqué à
halifax
nous nous avons pris un train pour
montréal
[Musique]
ces danses montréal du début des années
50 que la famille saputo cherche à
gagner sa vie en occupant des petits
boulots
[Musique]
pour permettre à son père de reprendre
son métier de fromager lino saputo donne
toutes ses économies pour fonder
l'entreprise familiale
une histoire qu'il a souvent raconté
comme lors de cette conférence de presse
en 2003 500 dollars pour acheter
l'équipement nécessaire tout commence à
faire le buzz qu'a mangé ma main puis la
bce pour faire les premières livraisons
en septembre 1954
giuseppe saputo est finie a vu le jour
les affaires vont bien on passe du vélo
à la camionnette pour les livraisons
en 1957
notre entreprise bien qu'encore modeste
avait grandi nous avons acquis une
propriété sur la 8e avenue dans le
quartier saint michel
nous les aidions à laitages et la
fromagerie occupé le rez de chaussée
[Musique]
mais au début des années 60
les problèmes commencent
la mafia qu'ils ont fuies en sicile et
installés dans la métropole elle est
dirigée d'une main de fer par victor ni
vincenzo cotroni et un trust you want
cadre à l'essor des petites séries avait
donné lieu à une féroce concurrence
notamment de la part d'individus
malhonnête parmi lesquels on comptait
des membres de la communauté italienne
désireux de prendre les commandes du
marché local
ceux ci n'hésitent pas à user de la
force
c'est la guerre du fromage la guerre de
la pizza l'unité spéciale d' enquêtes
sur le crime organisé de la police de
montréal compile les actes de violence
et de sabotage dans l'industrie du
fromage l'année 1963 et particulièrement
mouvementée ne du camion coupé l110
criminels à l'arrière de l'établissement
a séduit furic mélangé au lait en
fermentation explosion à l'intérieur de
l'entrée avant
lino saputo va aussi goûté à la médecine
des individus malhonnêtes en mai 1963
alors qu'il livre du fromage un
restaurant près de la petite italie il
est violemment b dessus dès que je suis
entré on m'a conduit au sous sol
là je me suis retrouvé dans une pièce
obscure où trois hommes ont attaqué
plein de s'est jeté sur moi
armé de ce qui m'a semblé être une batte
de baseball ils m'ont joint de ces
scènes d activité et de quitter
l'industrie
j'étais pétrifiée quelques minutes plus
tard se sont enfuis me laisse en plan
[Musique]
selon sa version lino saputo ne sais pas
du moins avec certitude qui sont ces
assaillants
je ne souhaitais pas émettre
d'hypothèses quant à l'identité de mes
agresseurs ni accuser quelqu'un tort
mais selon les rapports de police que
nous avons obtenu des ténois au
restaurant ont reconnu les truands
parmi eux par l'eau violi qui sera
accusée de l'agression de lino saputo
je lis en mélangeant montréal jean
pierre charbonneau connaît très bien la
mafia il a écrit un livre de référence
et il a travaillé à la commission d'
enquête sur le crime organisé
la ceco la seco avait identifié le gros
comme étant le groupe cotroni violiste
dire qu'il y ait deux ensembles faisait
l'appel et par plusieurs années ont eu
le haut du pavé sur la pègre québécoise
et montréalaise
finalement le chef mafieux paolo violi
est acquitté de l'agression de lino
saputo
les témoins se sont désistés mais
étonnamment même si par love you lie a
été identifié comme son agresseur
cela n'empêche pas lino saputo de le
fréquenter par la suite il se rend aux
funérailles du frère de viol y en 70
puis au baptême de l'un de ses enfants
la même époque pour ce reportage
lino saputo a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue
mais en réponse à nos questions sur les
liens avec paolo violi et des cotroni
son avocat nous a écrit que de tels
contacts son inévitable lorsqu'on évolue
comme monsieur saputo où sein d'une
petite communauté comme la communauté
italienne inévitable cette réponse
étonne parce que lino saputo a aussi
choisi de faire des affaires avec violi
cotroni tomber contre dix c'était le
dirigeable de l'appui aux organisations
criminelles du québec et du canada à
l'époque d'une organisation criminelle
qui est tentaculaire qui dans le fond
trempé noté grec nous
ont obtenu des centaines de rapports
policiers rédigé sur le clan violi
cotroni pendant les années 70 plusieurs
d'entre eux font état de rencontres
entre les chefs mafieux et lino saputo
lino saputo qui lui conseillaient dans
leur entreprise de pepperoni
[Musique]
saputo était également un distributeur
de leurs produits à la fin des années 70
il avait été confronté sur ce lien avec
vic cotroni par nos collègues de siby si
yu nan mais bizarre étrange relation que
celle de lino saputo avec les dirigeants
de la mafia montréal de l'époque dont
l'un d'eux a de surcroît été identifiés
comme son agresseur
d'autant plus que dans sa biographie
lino saputo fait une profession de foi
anti crime organisé mon père et mon
grand-père maternel m'enseigner à ne
jamais faire de mal à autrui et à ne pas
fréquenter ce qu'ils recouraient à la
violence le respectons la loi nous nous
tenions loin des organisations
criminelles évitions de leur chercher
querelle ne pas fréquenter ceux qui
recourent à la violence se tenir loin
des organisations criminelles
lino saputo a oublié parler de sa
relation avec violi et cotroni midi là
aussi d'autres trous de mémoire
mon père est décédé le 8 juin 1981
cette disparition a été une lourde perte
pour moi c'est au décès du patriarche
giuseppe saputo que lino saputo prend
complètement les commandes de
l'entreprise et il a de grandes
ambitions
je nous imaginaient devenir
transformateurs laitiers de premier rang
les fromage saputo deviendrait une
entreprise multinationale lino saputo de
vie un homme d'affaires de plus en plus
en vue et respectée
son entreprise prend de l'expansion à
l'extérieur du québec
on semble à des années-lumière de la
guerre du fromage et des mafieux qu'à
fréquenter lino saputo dans les années
60 et 70 mais ses relations sulfureuses
ne sont pas dans le passé
regardez bien la vidéo qui suit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur le plancher danse d'une réception de
mariage on se déhanchent au son du
dernier tube de michael jackson
nous sommes en 1983
le marié c'est lui donald côté la mariée
c'est elle barbara villon reculant la
vidéo au début de cette vidéo obtenu
d'une source confidentielle
on voit que le groupe semble vivre dans
la tranquillité de la campagne mais que
fait ce donald côté dans la vie
pour le savons nous sommes allés à la
bibliothèque nationale fouiller dans les
archives des journaux des décennies 60
70 et 80
ces documents sont conservés sur
microfilms
on découvre que donald côté a souvent
fait par les pluies
c'est officiellement un bijoutier au jeu
c'est un bijou tiens ça va être un bijou
tirerait pas trop parler de lui cet
outil leur clapet date soit d'arak
oui sinon les affaires judiciaires de la
prince accusé de voies de fait avec
l'intention de mutiler ou de défigurer
monsieur cousineau un criminel violence
nous découvrons qu'au début des années
60 il a été condamné pour avoir battu
sauvagement un opposant politique d'un
maire d'une municipalité de la rive-sud
de montréal dont un côté est
c'était pas du menu fretin c'est un
caillou c est quelqu un qui avait
atteint cavale il y avait les échelons
et les ja qu'il fréquentait c'était les
plus hauts personnages de ce qu'on
appelle le crime organisé il est aussi
accusé et reconnu coupable d'avoir
importé illégalement des diamants au
canada avec une complice
la jeune femme aurait eu 20 mille
dollars de diamants dissimulé sur sa
personne
il sera aussi accusé dans deux affaires
de meurtre mais ne sera pas reconnue
coupable
les deux hommes avait été criblé de
balles avant la dépose un coffre d'une
automobile qui on avait un certain sens
ok il est temps maintenant janvier 80
moins de trois années avant son mariage
donald côté fait la une du journal de
montréal pour une affaire de cocaïne
il sera toutefois acquitté
pendant son mariage il attend son procès
pour une grosse fraude de près de 2
millions $
défilent à l'idée mais l'une d'eux
qu'ils étaient peut-être que je tenais
partance une personne que j'aime bien
krieber barbara vuillon la femme avec
laquelle donald côté va se marier a
aussi des antécédents judiciaires avant
de changer de nom elle s'appelait marie
louise nollen c'était elle la complice
de côté dans la sphère des diamants et
porter illégalement le couple était
aussi soupçonnée de tromper dans le
trafic de drogue
les bras levés au ciel marie guillon
avançons plus loin dans la vidéo comment
la réception du mariage on aperçoit lino
saputo à la table des desserts un homme
d'affaires respectable
que c'est-il donald côté et pourtant
acoquiné à l'époque avec les plus
illustres membres de la mafia
le miel et cotonou
eh ben on a la cote étaient très proches
même est affichée par les policiers
comme étant un dac connaît quelqu'un d'à
très près du giro aussi de par nos
vianney rappelons les propres paroles de
lino saputo dans son autobiographie ne
pas fréquenter ceux qui recourent à la
violence se tenir loin des organisations
criminelles
pourtant lino saputo n'était pas un
invité ordinaire au mariage il était le
témoin de donald côté
beaucoup
sa femme mirella saputo était témoin de
la mariée lors de la réception
lino saputo et sa femme sont à la table
d'honneur
nous avons posé des questions à lino
saputo sur sa relation avec donald côté
mais dans la lettre de son avocat
il ne dit pas un mot sur ce sujet
[Musique]
les mariés sont heureux la soirée se
termine les couples dansent
vaud
[Musique]
new york new york c'est justement dans
cette étape que nous découvrirons des
liens encore plus étroits entre lino
saputo est l'un des plus importants
mafieux de l'histoire des états unis
[Applaudissements]
lino saputo se fait rare en entrevue
créée en 2007 nous avions fait
connaissance lors de sa tournée des
médias pour démentir des allégations qui
l'associé au crime organisé
moi j'ai aussi que je ne suis pas
impliqué pour aucune considération quand
l'associent à la mafia lino saputo
hausse le temps je puis vous garantir
que jamais soit des prêts aux dés loin
dans mafia était associé avec sa photo
la famille saputo
ok on l'entourage de cette route
régionale
les fausses rumeurs selon lui découle
d'un événement survenu dans les années
60 qu'il qualifie d' erreur de parcours
on parle de l'année 60 300 p 4 vous
savez c'est une lettre qui m'appelle
havas signé à l'époque pour inviter
monsieur banane on a participé dans son
entreprise à l'époque
monsieur bonanno ces jo bon anneaux
longtemps le mafioso le plus puissant
d'amérique corruption trafic de drogue
et meurtre
la lettre la voix si chère mme subow
nano vos conseils nous ont été très
utiles au fil des ans
nous sommes prêts à vous donner 20 % des
parts dans nos compagnies contre un
investissement d'environ 8000 $ au même
moment vont à nos essais d'immigrer au
canada avec l'appui des saputo
mais huit jours après la fameuse lettre
d'entente il fait la manche est jugée
indésirable
le joseph daul à nos candidats à la
citoyenneté canadienne a été refoulé aux
états unis d'ordre de la cour
on le soupçonne d'être l'un des chefs de
la cosa nostra d'organisations
internationales de maltais 2
mais comme on pay as eu la réputation de
monsieur von ah non il n'y a jamais
donné suite à lattes ya jamais une
transe à siaugues été fait
lino saputo a répété cette explication à
plusieurs reprises
aucun lien avec joe bonanno après 1964
malgré tout cette affaire lui colle à la
peau aux tentatives visant à investir
dans le marché de l'ontario du vermont
et de l'état de new york ont échoué en
grande partie en raison des allégations
criminelles que les médias avaient fait
peser sur nous
[Applaudissements]
quel allégations criminelles
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans l'état de
new york pour comprendre
nous allons à la bibliothèque d'albanie
la capitale de l'état de new york
à l'aube des années 80 lino saputo
demandent un permis pour faire le
commerce du lait mais le département de
l'agriculture de l'état new york s'y
oppose et tient des audiences pour
éclaircir les liens entre joe bonanno et
saputo
ça c'est plus peur jb regarde tout de
ses audiences la preuve les
transcriptions des témoignages a été
conservée y tient sur ses feuilles de
plastique
on ne veut ni non plusieurs fois des
milliers de pages car cette simple
affaire administrative s'est transformé
en enquête d'envergure des policiers de
plusieurs états américains du fbi haye
et de la grc au canada sont mises à
contribution
jimmy manyi
ça vous êtes un témoin important à
l'époque dans cette affaire puis dix
jours d'audience avec beats témoins dont
un certain jean amène qui semble avoir
dit des choses importantes
c'est un policier de l'arizona là où
habitait jo bonanno nous allons tenter
de le retrouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le voici ce témoin-clé ce fameux jean m
c'est un ex agent du fbi et de la police
de l'état de l'arizona walkway c'est un
quartier tranquille très sécuritaire
[Musique]
cinéma nous guide à tous sens dans
l'arizona dans le quartier où habite et
le chef mafieux jo bonanno le policier à
la retraite et le des rares à lui avoir
passé les menottes après avoir enquêté
sur lui pendant des années c'est la
réussir à vista son adresse était de 255
il ya une grosse poubelle
environ 1 100 verges sa maison sera sur
la droite
la voici la maison où l'ex paraît de la
mafia jo bonanno de murray c'est ici que
jean et mener sa petite équipe on est
une opération hors du commun dans les
années 70 fouiller les poubelles de joe
boehner
deux poubelles en acier galvanisé côte à
côte sauvage
l'opération secrète des policiers
éboueurs sur trois ans et demi comme on
le voit sur ces photos elle était
chorégraphié avec précision 45 secondes
top chrono
jean et mener un collègue était dans
cette fourgonnette il arrêtait devant la
maison de bananes au chaque matin de la
collecte des ordures
jacques après les poubelles et les tirs
est au fond de la camionnette vers mon
collègue prenait les sacs de bonanno il
est remplacé par d'autres 5 et je
remettais les poubelles sur le trottoir
on en est où il doit voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les poubelles les policiers
découvrent des bouts de papiers déchirés
djobo nano est un mafieux organisé il se
fait constamment des listes de choses à
faire en le surveillant et en l'étudiant
nous avons appris qu'il était le mafieux
le plus puissant des états unis et qu'il
avait une influence au canada les notes
de jawbone anneaux sont triés et
recoller dans un bureau police secret à
l'arrière d'un magasin de meubles de
tous en prennent aux morts avec ses
notes on a commencé à comprendre ses
habitudes il a plu au canada c'est
souvent et pourquoi plait-il au canada
assez souvent
nous avons découvert avec les notes
qu'il avait un intérêt financier dans
les formats chapoutot un intérêt secrets
cachés du public
après un certain temps les policiers ont
assez de preuves et obtienne un mandat
pour perquisitionner chez jo bonanno ils
saisissent des boîtes de documents
nous sommes en 1979 mais la collecte des
ordures qui suit leur apprend qu'ils
n'ont pas tous trouvé des zèbres un jour
après la perquisition il a sorti ses
poubelles comme d'habitude et je t'ai
1200 nouvelles notes de toute évidence
il a paniqué il voulait se débarrasser
ces documents qui le liait encore plus
étroitement avec les fromage saputo quid
se procurer les documents démontrent que
la relation entre joe bonanno et lino
saputo et soutenu v6 il semble que non
seulement il faisait des affaires
ensemble
mais leur relation était très amicale b
il semblait interagir de manière très
harmonieuse
c'était une relation de longue date sûr
que nous aurons encore jean emon et ses
collègues ont recueilli plusieurs autres
documents sur saputo et j'ai une copie
de ces notes de toutes les notes n'amène
nous invite chez lui
oui
donc ce sont toutes vos archives
personnelles vous n'avez pas vu ces bois
depuis plus de trente ans quand tu
attends
jean emon nous attendait pour se
replonger dans cette enquête
parce qu'au moment de notre visite il
venait tout juste de récupérer ses vues
document ces documents sont en français
ça semble être de la documentation que
saputo a fourni à jo bonanno pour
montrer ce qui se passait dans la
compagnie saputo
non seulement giorgo nano avait dit
documents financiers internes de
l'entreprise saputo
mais le terme liquide eau ou argent
comptant revient souvent dans les notes
du mafieux en référence à saputo et les
policiers ont aussi retrouvé cet objet
révélateur dans les poubelles de bonanno
ce ruban attaché à une liasse de 1000 $
moi ça faisait partie d'un transfert de
50 mille dollars
selon l' enquête policière cet argent
comptant provenaient d'entreprises liées
à saputo
pour le juge jacques brel ce n'est pas
une simple théorie policière le juge l'a
été en était un éminent juriste pendant
12 ans il a siégé ici dans la cour
d'appel de l'état de new york dont il
était le juge en chef
une fois à la retraite c'est lui qui a
présidé l enquête administrative sur la
demande de permis pour faire le commerce
du les cas demandez lino saputo
les audiences se sont tenues à albany en
1981 ici dans cette salle le juge
brighton a entendu les arguments des
deux côtés il a conclu que bono avait
bel et bien une relation avec les
fromages saputo lino saputo a témoigné
pour nier ses liens avec joe bonanno il
a déposé cette lettre du juge denis
dionne le juge dionne a présidé la
commission enquête sur le crime organisé
au québec il écrit qu'il n'a pris
connaissance d'aucun élément qui
justifierait une enquête sur les saputo
me cela n'a pas fait le poids pour les
juges brighton
il a rejeté leur demande de permis dans
l'état de new york
c'était un revers gigantesque parce que
c'était déjà une entreprise qui brassait
des millions de dollars
dans son livre
lino saputo passe très vite sur ces
événements il n'en parle que pour
remercier ceux qui ont témoigné en sa
faveur même si le juge a rejeté notre
demande au terme de l'audience
leur geste m'a beaucoup touché mais lino
saputo ne dit pas un mot sur les
conclusions accablantes juge peu interne
notamment que le chef mafieux avait bel
et bien des parts dans les compagnies d
saputo
joseph bonanno avait un intérêt
économique significatif sur une période
de temps considérable avec plusieurs
entreprises canadiennes de fromage
appartenant des membres de la famille
saputo et à lino saputo en particulier
les enjeux est très grand bond à nous
était connu dans l'état de new york
louis nom figurer nous dit simplement
c'était lui le fameux les juges bras et
elle a aussi conclu que lino saputo a
menti
lino saputo a tenté de cacher son
implication et celle de ses entreprises
avec bonanno et il a fait des
déclarations fausses et trompeuses
l'un des mensonges de lino saputo c'est
une visite clandestine documenté par le
fbi haye et dont lino saputo n'avait
aucun souvenir
contrairement à ses affirmations lino et
sa femme ont bien rencontré joe bolano à
tout sonne au début de 1966
mais quand mon père y as eu la
réputation de monsieur bonhomme n'y a
jamais donné suite à lattes ya jamais
intrants sa soeur était fait les
documents retrouvés par jean heyman et
ses collègues prouve une relation
beaucoup plus longue qui a duré au moins
jusqu'à la fin des années 70 mais ce
n'est pas tout dans les notes
il y a un nom qui nous intrigue beaucoup
pépé fredo boufferez 12 suivi le numéro
de téléphone à montréal
nous appelons
[Musique]
ap
revenons à tous en en arizona nous
appelons pp fredo ce nom de code et son
numéro de téléphone apparaissent à
plusieurs reprises dans les notes du
chef mafieux jo bonanno en lien avec les
non c'est plutôt à la fin des années
soixante dix
pas de réponse mais qui est ce pp fredo
si important dans l' enquête de jean mn
avec l'aide de la gendarmerie royale du
canada
il a fini par découvrir sa véritable
identité
19 on avait des noms liés à des numéros
de téléphone la grc nous a appris à qui
il appartenait donc acquis bonanno
parlait pp serait doux fait partie de la
famille ça plutôt comme à l'époque il
habite toujours cette résidence cossue
de montréal et c'est un important homme
d'affaires
nous allons bientôt vous dire de qui il
s'agit
[Musique]
regardons d'abord ce document inédit qui
le concerne
un document exceptionnel que nous avons
obtenus d'une source confidentielle
[Musique]
c'est une vidéo d'une fête familiale
chez les rizzuto à montréal
ces images ont été captées en 1995 à
l'occasion du 50e anniversaire de
mariage de nicolo rizutto et libertina
manno à cette époque
nicolo rizutto n'est rien moins que le
parrain du crime organisé au canada
l'un des moments forts de la vidéo c'est
cette scène surréaliste devant la maison
familiale des musiciens mettent de
l'ambiance pour les invités qui
attendent les jubilaires
et quand la famille sort de la maison
les musiciens entament le thème du film
le parrain
[Musique]
les rizutto affichent ouvertement leur
rendant la mafia
[Musique]
le fameux pp fredo maintes fois
mentionnée dans les notes de jawbone
anneaux est présent à la fête dans son
livre lino saputo part de lui à une
occasion nous avons fondé petra
aujourd'hui l'une des plus grandes
sociétés immobilières fermé au québec
avec à son actif plus de 8,3 millions de
pieds carrés à montréal mon cher ami et
beau frère giuseppe borsellino
on est le président pépé fredo c'est lui
giuseppe borsellino
il a épousé elina saputo la soeur de
lino bien qu'il soit beaucoup moins
connu du grand public que son beau frère
giuseppe borsellino est un maniaque de
l'immobilier à montréal giuseppe
borsellino est étroitement liée aux
entreprises de la famille saputo
depuis les années 60
l'enquète de jinmen dans les poubelles
de joe bonanno démontre que giuseppe
borsellino servait d'intermédiaire entre
le chef mafieux et lino saputo
c'est possible j'aimerais entendre la
voix de ton beau frère et parler avec
lui
rappelons le bien qu'il n'ait jamais été
formellement accusé de meurtre
djobo nano était un redoutable criminels
nous bonne
on savait que bono qui avait une
relation avec les saputo et les vols
cellino avec 80 meurtres à sa feuille de
route
certains qu'il avait commis lui-même
mais la plupart qu'il a commandés
c'était un homme violent
il a une relation avec reality show père
giuseppe borsellino
eh ben on and on se parlait au téléphone
il se donnait des rendez-vous de paie
pas cher pepo téléphone mois lundi le
1er décembre 1975 à 7 heures pm t-on
appris à mi-hauteur beaucoup de détails
liés à bord ces lignes l'heure à
laquelle il allait l'appeler ou qu'il
allait recevoir un appel à une certaine
cabine téléphonique à une date précise
et vous avez pu confirmer ça on l'a
confirmé parce qu'on surveillait les
cabines téléphoniques souvent il prenait
la même si suez dans le corridor de
l'hôpital
parfois mon collègue du fbi a et se
couchait sur une civière près du
téléphone pour entendre les
conversations
cette lettre de giuseppe borsellino
écrite au milieu des années 70 a
l'intention de giovanna nos en dit long
sur leur relation cheruiyot
je ne sais pas comment m'excuser pour
l'appel téléphonique que je n'ai pas
passé je sais que m'excuser ne sert à
rien mais je peux vous assurer que ce
jour là j'étais au tribunal pour une
petite affaire je me permet de joindre
ce courrier une photo de notre fille
afin que vous puissiez la connaître
j'espère que vous vous portez bien ainsi
que votre famille et en attendant de
vous parler au téléphone je vous envoie
me plus cordiales salutations
les notes de bons à nos indique que les
deux hommes parlaient aussi d'argent
quant à eux appelés bp fredo parler de
la grève des postiers et de l'argent
d'un kilo and money de retour à montréal
nous composons de nouveau le numéro de
téléphone de bp fredo qui se trouvaient
dans les poubelles de joe bonanno alors
oui bonjour j'aimerais parler avec
monsieur giuseppe borsellino s'il vous
plaît je suis bien la résidence de
monsieur borsellino une madame ça plutôt
[Musique]
ici toujours le numéro de téléphone de
giuseppe borsellino
il a refusé nous parler et lina saputo
aussi dans une lettre leurs avocats
affirment que monsieur borsellino n'a
rien à se reprocher dans ces boîtes jean
et mène à retrouver un compte rendu
d'une conversation entre les policiers
de l'arizona et la grc datant de 1976 au
sujet de lino saputo et giuseppe
borsellino les saputo sont connus comme
des acteurs du crime organisé et ils
sont sous enquête depuis des années qu
en fait les autorités canadiennes avec
toutes les informations retrouvé dans
les poubelles de giovanna no je sais
qu'ils ont perquisitionné le domicile de
saputo
je ne sais pas quel a été le résultat et
je n'ai pas eu connaissance d'aucun
suivi
je ne sais pas tout ce que fait la grc
mais au meilleur de notre connaissance
ça s'est terminé la lino saputo et
giuseppe borsellino n'ont jamais fait
l'objet d'accusations
[Musique]
quinze ans après la fin de l' enquête de
jean amon on retrouve encore giuseppe
borsellino en présence de dirigeants de
la mafia
de retour dans la résidence des
résultats en 1995
les anciens représentants du clan
bonanno à montréal paolo violi et vic
cotroni sont morts ce sont maintenant
nicolo rizutto et son fils vito qui sont
aux commandes de la mafia le jour des
noces d'or
ils reçoivent des gens proches dans leur
maison dont certains criminels de haut
rang comme c'est important trafiquant
d'héroïne condamn é on en profite aussi
pour prendre des photos de famille
quelques personnes ont le privilège de
se faire photographier avec le parrain
de la mafia
parmi eux et lina saputo et giuseppe
borsellino
et selon des documents de renseignements
policiers du cp borsellino a poursuivi
ses contacts avec des membres du clan
rizutto au moins jusqu'au milieu des
années 2000 nous avons demandé à lino
saputo de commenter les contacts de son
beau-frère avec les réseaux d'eau il n'a
pas répondu à cette question
mon rêve ça toujours été de laisser une
bonne réputation
puis je vais la laisser la bonne
réputation pourquoi lino saputo at il
décidé de publier un livre dans lequel
il répète ses mensonges sur sa relation
avec joe bonanno
we dance à la même chose pour notre
bonheur
pourquoi mentir depuis des décennies en
niant tout lien avec le crime organisé
plus vous garantir que jamais soit des
prêts aux des noirs dans mafia était
associé avec saputo à la famille sa pop
au hockey au l'entourage de sa pipe
parce que cela aurait certainement
compromis les entrées de la famille
saputo dans la communauté des affaires
la nomination de lino saputo à la banque
nationale où il a siégé au conseil
d'administration pendant dix ans à l'
influence politique de la famille
giuseppe borsellino était un collecteur
de fonds officiel du parti libéral du
québec à la remise de récompenses comme
ce doctorat honorifique qu'il a reçus de
l'université concordia aux décorations
les plus prestigieuses
lino saputo au nom du peuple québécois
je vous fait officier de l'ordre
national du québec aux plus grands
pays comme de recevoir l'ordre du canada
des mains du gouverneur général
est-ce que leno saputo aurait été autant
applaudi par la société québécoise et
canadienne
s'il avait dit la vérité sur ses liens
passés avec le crime organisé
[Applaudissements]